remember that book um
all's quiet on the western front world
war one there's this line in there i
forget what it is about how war is like
the smell of a skunk
like a little bit is actually a little
is slightly um
there's something slightly delicious of
it is what it says in the in the book um
i happen to like the smell of like
ferrets and skunks and things i had a
pet ferret when i was a kid and i like
that musky scent people most people just
it's repulsive to them it's actually a
gene believe it or not some people have
the gene that makes that
the musky scent repulsive some people
love it um
let me ask you this there's another gene
this is a fun one um microwave popcorn
smells good neutral or disgusting to you
good very good there are people who have
a gene that
leads them to the perception that the
smell of microwave popcorn that you find
is good it smells like putrid vomit to
them it's a particular
gene variant and they can smell certain
elements within the microwave popcorn um
it's pretty it's prominent in france the
uh this gene and um so in laboratories
where
uh you have a lot of french people it's
often said like you're not allowed to
make microwave popcorn smells putrid
disgusting you know so a lot of it's in
the perception of the beholder
you